we all know
uh the great hymn with which the eighth
symphony of mala starts
veni creato spiritus which is you know a
kind of expression of what
what the arts can do if any creator
spiritus i mean
what what the creative spirit which is
not
uh equal with the scientific spirit what
the creative spirits can do
and art can transform society the greek
tragedies
uh uh uh did it in a certain way
beethoven
earlier that unfortunately successful
richard wagner did
were always and the b generation in a
certain way uh
did it in the rolling stones and david
bowie um so
the power of art to transform
where is it and and and and and and
uh and why is and why is music so
powerful
why is it sorry why is music so powerful
it's very
i mean i'm very suspicious of in myself
of any argument that says that art is
transformative or can be the foundation
for any sort of
um sense of the other i think having
lost
most of us the sense of this other power
the religious
the religious side of music has become
thinner um and i think we just have to
see music as i supposed as being part of
the good life in an epicurean way i
don't i mean
at the same time i see in myself a
feeling listening to music that
what is so extraordinary about music is
that it's a language that doesn't
doesn't have any particular defined
meaning it's not language and it it
talks about things
that we can't talk about in words and
that's a very powerful
social technology i suppose and it can
move you yes
music is it's my for me it's like the
best
yeah but it goes up to your heart but it
talks about things that we can't talk
about rationally like
it's true i mean i know scientists try
and talk about time and
you know color revelli will write a book
about the nature of time and time in
relativistic and quantum mechanics and
this sort of thing but that's not really
our experience of
our experience of time isn't it it's a
mysterious thing i think but therefore i
think
it's not so much i i i totally agree
with you
that that i also i'm not a believer
that art really can change you know
or transform i'm not sure of that but i
i
i think what you're saying is that art
has a
there's a vital force within a society
where art has has its place and it's
really important
you know it's and really necessary i
think
think of all the uh
we have our lives are full of rituals
funerals birth anniversaries marriages
whatever uh uh whatever that's
stage that's like it's directed it's it
has a
structure you know and it's a structure
leading to a catharsis
always you know that that that
that's also so painful now that people
have cannot be together for funerals
you know because if you miss that moment
that you can really release that energy
and you can think okay it's it's good
you know this morning process
how short it is how long it is but we
need that you know and i think that's
also what art
gives art we we also create forms
so that you can be moved because at the
end of the day i think theater
of course it's it's also food for
thought also
but it's it's basically the best theater
and the best opera
it's when these two things come together
when thought and emotions and this
the emotional life come together and
that's what what art can do what
what a great novel can do what music can
do what theater can do what opera can do
there's no guarantee that it will do
good in the same way
there's no guarantee that science will
do good i mean there's this line no
poetry after auschwitz and there's
george stein's argument about all these
people listening to haydn and mozart
as they were doing these terrible things
but it's the same with that there were
people there were scientists pursuing
sick science but they would they i mean
there's no guarantee when you
engage with art that you're doing
something good but it's nevertheless
part of
it's part of human existence
you